What I'm going
to do in this class
is use the lessons of history
to apply to your daily life.
That's what I love
about history.
It can really give you
perspective, solace,
and give you hope.
I will use examples
from the four presidents
I know the best--
Abraham Lincoln, Teddy
Roosevelt, Franklin Roosevelt,
and Lyndon Johnson.
Each one of these
presidents was a leader
during a time of great crisis.
We can learn from their
failures and their ability
to acknowledge those failures
and learn from their mistakes.
I'd love to just
transport them into you.
Think of what you learned
from parents, from people
who have experience.
You're learning from generations
that lived before us.
It makes you feel you're
part of a continuum.
You're not just here alone, so
it makes you a deeper person
and maybe even gives you that
great thing called wisdom.
I think about Abraham Lincoln,
as he scoured the countryside
for books and he read everything
he could lay his hands on.
He understood that he
was a work in progress.
Nobody's going to be perfect.
The most important thing
for a leader to develop
is the ability to grow.
All of us in our lives are
going to suffer difficult times,
and the question is,
can you get through it?
Can you grow through it?
Can you learn from it?
I'm Doris Kearns Goodwin,
and this is my MasterClass.